pero la diferencia entre una idea verdaderamente genial y divertida
y algo que en realidad podamos usar
es superar estos desafíos prácticos.
Aunque el ADN es más robusto que cualquier dispositivo hecho por el hombre,
no es perfecto.
Tiene algunas debilidades.
Recuperamos nuestro mensaje secuenciando el ADN,
y cada vez que los datos se recuperan, perdemos el ADN.
Es parte del proceso de secuenciación.
No queremos quedarnos sin datos,
pero por suerte existe una forma de copiar el ADN
que es incluso más barata y sencilla que sintetizarlo.
Probamos una forma de hacer 200 billones de copias
de nuestros archivos, y recuperamos todos nuestros datos sin ningún error.
La secuenciación también introduce errores en nuestro ADN,
dentro de las A, las T, las C y las G.
La naturaleza resuelve esto en nuestras células.
Pero nuestros datos son almacenados en ADN sintético dentro de un tubo,
por lo que tuvimos que encontrar nuestra forma de solucionar este problema.
Decidimos usar un algoritmo que se usa para reproducir videos.
Al reproducir un video,
esencialmente lo que se hace es recuperar el video original, el archivo original.
Cuando tratamos de recuperar nuestros archivos originales,
simplemente secuenciamos.
Pero en realidad ambos procesos se basan en recuperar suficientes ceros y unos
para volver a juntar nuestros datos.
Debido a nuestra estrategia de codificación
pudimos empaquetar todos nuestros datos
de forma tal que nos permitiera hacer millones y billones de copias
y aun así recuperar siempre todos nuestros archivos.
Esta es la película que codificamos.
Es de las primeras películas filmadas,
y ahora la primera en ser copiada más de 200 billones de veces en ADN.
Poco después de la publicación de nuestro trabajo,
participamos en un "Ask me Anything" en la página web de reddit.
Si son colegas nerd, estarán muy familiarizados con esta página.
La mayoría de preguntas fueron sesudas.
Algunas fueron cómicas.
Por ejemplo, un usuario quería saber cuándo tendría un dispositivo en su pulgar
Ahora bien, la cuestión es
nuestro ADN ya almacena todo lo necesario para hacernos quienes somos.
Es mucho más seguro almacenar datos en ADN,
en ADN sintético en un tubo.
Escribir y leer datos del ADN obviamente requiere mucho más tiempo
que simplemente guardar todos los archivos en un disco duro.
Por ahora.
Inicialmente, debemos centrarnos en el almacenamiento a largo plazo.
La mayoría de los datos son efímeros.
Es más difícil entender qué es importante hoy en día,
o qué será importante para las futuras generaciones.
Pero el punto es que no tenemos que decidirlo ahora.
Hay un programa fantástico de la UNESCO llamado "Memoria del Mundo".
Se creó para preservar materiales históricos
que se consideran valiosos para toda la humanidad.
Los objetos son nominados para sumarse a la colección,
como esa película que codificamos.
Aunque es una maravillosa forma de preservar el patrimonio humano,
no tiene que ser una opción.
En lugar de preguntar a la generación actual, a nosotros,
qué podría ser importante en el futuro,
podríamos almacenar todo en el ADN.
El almacenamiento no se basa solo en la cantidad de bytes,
sino en cuán bien podemos almacenar los datos y recuperarlos.
Siempre ha habido esta tensión entre cuántos datos podemos generar
y cuántos podemos recuperar,
y cuántos podemos almacenar.
Cada avance en la escritura de datos requiere una nueva forma de leerlos.
Ya no podemos leer los medios antiguos.
¿Cuántos de Uds. tienen una lectora de discos en su portátil?
Ni hablar de una lectora de disquetes.
Esto nunca sucederá con la lectura del ADN.
Mientras estemos aquí, el ADN está aquí,
y encontraremos formas de secuenciarlo.
Archivar el mundo que nos rodea es parte de la naturaleza humana.
Este es el progreso que logramos en el almacenamiento digital en 60 años,
en un momento en que apenas empezamos a entender el ADN.
Logramos un progreso similar en la mitad de tiempo con los secuenciadores de ADN,
y mientras existamos nuestro ADN nunca estará obsoleto.
Gracias
(Aplausos)